äh 60% der deutschen schaffen es nicht
mehr neue Ersparnisse zu bilden die
Leben von der Hand in den Mund und das
ist bis weit in die Mittelschicht
vorangedrückt unser Finanzminister
Christian nennt man versucht das jetzt
mit der Schuldenbremse zu bekämpfen
nehme einfach sagt die Schuldenbremse
ist jetzt auch eine inflationsbremse
nichts könnte tatsächlich aber falscher
sein denn die Ampel hat ja Milliarden
Pakete mit dem doppelwurm zum
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsform mit drei
entlastungspaketen aufgelegt Schulden
gemacht sehr viele richtige Sachen
gemacht und strompreisbremse eine
gaspreisbremse um was ja um die Preise
runter zu drücken vieles davon hat
funktioniert vieles davon Entlastung
gesorgt aber er mal die Ampel macht noch
lange nicht genug und wir haben gerade
über die Preise in den Supermärkten
gesprochen Lebensmittel sind
Preistreiber Nummer eins es gibt eine
Preisbremse Strom und für Gas aber warum
gibt es keine Preisbremse im Supermarkt
die Leute merken noch nicht dass die
Preise günstiger geworden sind eine
Sache liegt auf der Hand müsste auch der
FDP gefallen
Steuern streichen auf
Grundnahrungsmittel das ist laut
EU-Recht seit 22 erlaubt es wurde sofort
Brot und Butter 7% günstiger machen wenn
der Mehrwertsteuersatz da wegfällt
Christian Lindner will das nicht weil
gerade bei der Mehrwertsteuer ist er der
heimliche Gewinner auf Kosten der Leute
deswegen mein Vorschlag weg mit der
Mehrwertsteuer auf Grundnahrungsmittel
sowieso eine beknackte Idee was pauschal
teuer zu machen was ja jeder braucht
jeder von uns muss essen brotbutter ist
ein Grundnahrungsmittel weg mit der
Steuer und wen machen sie sich derzeit
am meisten Sorgen welche
Bevölkerungsgruppe haben sie da im Auge
wo sie sagen da wird es jetzt bald
richtig schwierig diejenigen die ein
kleines Einkommen haben ganz klar aber
nicht nur das auch kleine Unternehmen
ich sag mal das ganz klassische
innenstadtgewerbe der Bäcker der
Textilhandel der Friseur die sind
nämlich zweifach von dem Preis Schock
betroffen einerseits zahlen Sie selber
selber höhere Energiepreise die Kosten
gehen durch die Decke anderer bereits
fehlen den Leuten die Euros die
Kaufkraft um überhaupt noch zum Friseur
zu gehen dann gehen sie seltener zum
Friseur was macht das mit dem Friseur
höhere Kosten weniger Nachfrage das ist
ein Schock der auch unsere Innenstädte
treffen wird wir machen rein weil sie
dich letztes Jahr 3,3% haben
innensolvenz angemeldet und die Gewinner
das vielleicht auch noch dazu zu sagen
die sitzen die großen Energiekonzerne
allen voran in Deutschland RWE 22 bis
Zehnfache des Gewinns vom Vorjahr davon
wird nichts abgeschöpft es gibt zwar
eine Abschöpfung aber die greift erst ab
23 die gehen so durch ja und auf Kosten
der kleinen Leute ihr Vorschlag ist
jetzt noch mal zusammenzufassen da also
die Steuern runter die Steuern Weg
bedeutet aber auch dass die Menschen die
es vielleicht gar nicht nötig haben auch
davon profitieren ja aber das ist
vollkommen okay das wäre meine Gießkanne
trotzdem hilft weil die Idee jeder
braucht Lebensmittel wir machen die mit
einer Steuerpauschale teurer die die ist
Unsinn und im übrigen ist es so wenn die
Kassiererin im Supermarkt spart ja oder
der Busfahrer die ein kleineres
Einkommen haben den hilft das viel mehr
gemessen an ihrem Einkommen als der
Bankmanager oder der Intendanz die den
gucken eh nicht auf den Preis die gucken
ähnlich die packen einfach rein und gut
ist von daher sollten wir uns da nicht
der Erbsenzählerei verfallen sondern
raus Gießkanne und den Brand löschen
es gibt die sogenannte Kerninflation ja
und diese kennen Inflation gehört
erstaunlicherweise gehören nicht die
Preise für Lebensmittel und wie viel
Kraftstoffe und das sind die beiden
Inflationstreiber wieso nimmt man bei
dem verrechnen der Inflation
ausgerechnet die beiden Warengruppen
heraus die die Inflation in die gehört
treiben Lebensmittel und Kraftstoffe
müssen Sie die Statistiker Fragen aber
nein ich frage sie sind noch Ökonomen ja
ja selbst in der Kerninflation ist aber
Energie mit drin weil Energie ja nicht
nur Kraftstoff richtig sondern natürlich
arbeiten
Ausgaben die sind nicht in der Inflation
enthalten und der Begriff
Inflation deutet eigentlich daraufhin
dass er etwas trifft was wir täglich
brauchen aber auf die Kerninflationsrate
gucken die Leute ja gar nicht die gucken
auf die Preise im Supermarkt und ärgern
alles die ärgern sich über die Rechnung
vom Strom vom Gas verantwortliche
Feststellungen die amtliche sprech oder
Sprachregelung ist zur Inflation gehört
nicht die Kerninflation ja und wir
erleben die Inflation ganz anders wissen
sie das sind auch das wollte ich noch
kurz sagen was wir erleben ist auch
die Sprache die Viktor Klemperer in
seinem wunderbaren Buch lingua Terz in
Paris analysiert hat dass der
Zusammenbruch und der Abbau und die
Vernichtung und die Zerstörung der
Atomkraftwerke wird alles rückgebaut
das klingt eigentlich ganz okay Aufbau
Rückbau nein es ist ja nicht Vernichtung
es ist Zerstörung da wird enorme Werte
zerstört und der Vorschlag einige FDP
Leute die nicht richtig fand die
Kernkraftwerke Reserve zu halten und sie
nicht zu vernichten der ist vom Tisch in
Deutschland geht immer noch besser
und der Vernichtung muss bis zum Ende
getrieben werden händlagerung klingt
auch schon ein bisschen wie Endlösung
nicht wahr und bei einem eins haben wir
überhaupt mit keinem Wort erwähnt
die Haupt Betroffenen sind Familien mit
Kindern und wer das heute erlebt also
verstehen sie ich habe ja nah am Wasser
gebaut aber man kann nur noch heulen ich
habe gestern einen Jungen gesehen der
von der Schule kam mit mit Schulranzen
der hatte ganz sauber angezogen billigst
Ware billig hoch billig aber ganz sauber
hatte zwei riesige Taschen und sammelte
Flaschen das heißt wenn Kinder in
Deutschland schon anfangen Flaschen
zusammen und es ist einfach schlimm und
aber was sie jetzt sagen mit den
Friseuren z.B zur Wahrheit auch wenn das
gesamte arabische
einwanderungspotenzial was wir 2015 von
Frau Merkel geerbt haben die
Friseursalons aufmacht und in vielen
Branchen haben deutsche überhaupt keine
Chance mehr weil sie viel zu wenig Geld
verdienen das System als Marktwirtschaft
ja es ist einfach aber für mich ist es
ein ganz großes Thema das heute Familien
mit Kindern und wenn sie ja drei Kinder
haben dann gelten sie ja als asozial das
ist ja warm können
es gibt über 150 Hilfsprogramme auf
Bundes- und Länderebene um Familien mit
Kindern zu helfen 150 Programme es ist
ja Programm wird genug geholfen herzlich
nicht das frage ich mich die ganze Zeit
wohin ich frage mich die ganze Zeit
wieso kein Geld da ist oder die Leute
merken das nicht 9€
von Bad reichen halt wenn das Flensburg
fahren sie merken nur nicht dass sie mir
das Geld auf der einen Tasche in die
andere Tasche
aber auch Beipackzettel in gendersprache
nein dafür aber keine Medikamente keine
wir haben gendersprache im Zug aber wie
es fährt kein Zug mehr ja aber wir
können doch nicht alles auf einmal haben
wirklich es geht ja um die Programme die
wir haben wir machen die sinnlosesten
Sachen statt sie müssen doch mal
Prioritäten setzen muss ich
ehrlicherweise sagen arabischen Friseur
ganzem Herzen ja es war nur ein kleines
Beispiel das Mega Aktion auch eine Rolle
spielen Meditation verursacht Kosten
aber die arabischen Friseure sind
genauso wie die türkischen Gemüsehändler
ein positiver Faktor innerhalb der
Wirtschaft bleiben wir mal kurz bei dem
jungen der Pfandflaschen ja für den soll
ja jetzt gerade eigentlich auch was
kommen nämlich die sogenannte Kinder
Grundsicherung Christian Linda will nur
dass die drei Milliarden kostet die
Familienministerin sagt nee wir brauchen
zwölf Milliarden schon um das vernünftig
zu machen und da frage ich mich warum
wird da jetzt genau das ist der
Hauptstreitpunkt gerade wie kann das
sein dass eine alternde Gesellschaft
nicht bereit ist die Milliarden für ihre
Jugend ausziehen müssen
nicht klar genug sind und dass man so
nicht wüsste wo das Geld hingeht bei der
Kind Grundsicherung deswegen kann man
das jetzt erstmal nicht machen so ein
bisschen wurde sich da rauslaviert es
liegt kein konkreter guter Plan vor hat
die FDP hat die Ampel all das aus den
Augen verloren auch wie wie es vielen
Familien wie es vielen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern überhaupt geht ganz im Gegenteil
also die FDP hat die insbesondere aber
auch die Kinder und die Familien erst
recht im Auge aus dem einfachen Grund
die Kinder Grundsicherung einfach nur
aufzustocken hilft nicht das Problem der
Kinderarmut zu bekämpfen wir haben sie
hat mich ja gesagt 50 Programme wir
haben aber auch
eben einmal also wir haben auch jetzt
schon Möglichkeiten Kinder zu
unterstützen nur viele wissen davon gar
nicht also wir haben ungefähr 15
Prozent abruft zum Beispiel können
Kinder Unterstützung oder die Eltern
Unterstützung kommen um die Kinder in
Vereine zu bringen das wissen viele gar
nicht und da ist der die Idee auch
insbesondere der FDP in Kinder
chancenportal zu machen wo man nämlich
genau nein nein nein ein Portalen Online
Portal würde mich genau
ja wo genau diese vielen Möglichkeiten
der unterstützen zusammengefasst werden
es nie so ähnlich wie in so einem
Warenkorb wo man sich diese
Notwendigkeiten die man hat Vereine
Bücher was auch immer sich da in den
Warenkorb zu legen um daran zu kommen
weil im Augenblick ist der Abruf viel zu
niedrig und würden wir bei dem Abruf von
15% auf möglicherweise 95% der jetzt
schon möglichen unterstützung kommt dann
wird das Geld Automat Schreibtisch mehr
was wir in dieses System gehen
nein dass das was mehr abgerufen wird
was jetzt schon möglich ist wird nicht
vollständig abgerufen
muss ich selber wir müssen ja wir müssen
dahin kommen dass das abgerufen wird ein
Familien zu sehr im Stich verloren in
der Bürokratie Bürokratie
ist das so und jetzt einfach zu sagen
als Lisa Pause als Ministerin wir
brauchen mehr Geld hilft nicht wenn wir
dieses Konzept nicht verändern und das
ist der der Ursprung des gesamten und
letztendlich ist es auch muss es auch
Ziel sein dass wir die Kinder die in
Armut leben oder die bedürftig sind dass
wir die gerne die Eltern ja
die Eltern dass wir den Eltern helfen
dass sie selbst das organisieren können
für Ihre aber das und das ist wichtig
und da ist Bildung wichtig da ist
Unterstützung
ganz tolle das wird das wissen wir alles
aber wissen Sie das könnten auch Sätze
aus den 60er Jahren sein das Gehäuse
seine Bildungskatastrophe veröffentlich
das zeigt er dass wir mindestens mal in
den letzten 16 Jahren fast ja
mit einem Konzept falsch liegen das mehr
Geld Probleme zu lösen im Stande ist das
ist es nur sehr bedingt aber das sind
doch nicht die FDP nein nein das hat
ein Beispiel
herangeführt werden wen wollen Sie noch
zu Tränke führen ich meine der Stadt
greift jetzt überall ein der greift ins
Familienleben meines Erwerbsleben ich
verstehe dass sie mehr Start wollen weil
sich davon angeht doch doch
mit den Pfandflaschen und der soll Geld
bekommen der soll auch Fußball spielen
gehen aber heute hat jemand was dagegen
gesagt ja gerade das System hat was
dagegen denn heute wenn er zu dem Verein
will dass der muss er aufwendig
Formulare ausfüllen um die 15 Euro
Mitgliedsbeitrag zu bekommen jetzt sagt
die Familienministerin komm drauf
geschissen wir zahlen die 15 € einfach
mit aus was sagt die FDP die
eigentlichen gegen Bürokratie ist die
sagt nein wir machen ein neues Portal da
gibt's ja keine Formulare zum ausfüllen
sondern muss man sich fast in den
Warenkorb legen 15 € für ein Sportverein
einfach mit auf den Regelsatz früher war
der aus dem Regelsatz mit drin das wird
Ursula von der Leyen rausgerechnet also
Erbsenzählerei bei den Jungen die die
alten übrigens irgendwann finanzieren
und versorgen müssen ist völlig fehl am
Platz der jungen der nämlich die
Pfandflaschen sammelt der hat schwerer
in der Schule der hat danach schwerer
sein ganzes Leben weniger Steuern zahlen
weniger Wohlstand erwirtschaften und
deswegen ja sowas vermeiden nicht an den
Kindern
nein das können sie nur machen über
Eingriffe in das Familien leben sie
Hebeln damit das Elternrecht aus ich bin
sehr dafür man muss die Kinder
Grundsicherung erhöhen natürlich den
Eltern wegnehmen
[Musik]
so konzipieren und das ist es im
Augenblick nicht man muss die Kinder
Grundsicherung so konzipieren dass sie
leicht abgerufen werden kann und man
braucht dafür nicht mehr Geld sondern
auch im Badezimmer aber bevor wir jetzt
hier in Jubel ausbrechen
bevor wir jetzt in Jubel ausbrechen zu
unserem Nesthäkchen sozusagen hoch ist
eins
Verschulden sie aber durch das was sie
jetzt alles fordern was jetzt noch sein
muss und Schuldenbremse weg und wer weiß
was alles dieser Junge mit den
Pfandflaschen und die wenigen Kinder die
wir noch haben müssen einmal diese
ganzen Schulden die heute gemacht werden
für nichts und wieder nichts zum Teil
also Klima Unterhaltung für Unsinn alles
die müssen es zurückzahlen das heißt sie
haben partiell diesen Jungen im
Sportverein mit den 15 €, der muss aber
wenn er mal 40 oder 50 ist äh die
Steuerschraube verkraften weil nämlich
das was sie fordern das muss ja nicht
viel Geld ist das muss ja nicht bis
dahin wird seine Währungsschnitt geben
es wird eine Entwertung geben es gibt
eine enorme Inflation und das wird nicht
nur die Besitzstände vermindern das wird
auch die Schuldenlast des Staates
vermindern und hier in diesem Land muss
ich sagen so ja ich weiß Sie sind bei
der linke deswegen müssen sie mit mir
nicht übereinstimmen das ist schon in
Ordnung so sie wollen einfach einfach
alles über die Steuern finanzieren das
gehen sie offenbar so eine magische
Formel haben dass mehr Steuern auch mehr
Vermögen für die Leute bedeutet das ist
nicht der Fall ich will finanzieren ich
sage jetzt gerade man muss neues Geld
erzeugen mehr Geld in den umleiten
solche Spiele aber wie kommt dein Geld
ja natürlich kommen wo kommen denn die
100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr her
das ist eine Größe die gibt's gar nicht
das natürlich ist Geld deswegen sage ich
sollten wir es für die richtigen Sachen
ausgeben Anhänger diese abenteuerlichen
Stadt praktisch wissen Sie wenn es so
wäre
die Bundeswehr her kam sagen
vielleicht auch aus ihren Stunde
gedruckt schön ja ja
daraufhin will ich hinaus wenn das neues
Geld ist und wenn ein Problem ist so
leicht lösen kann ja frage ich mich
wieso zieht der Stadt überhaupt noch
Steuern ein der könnte alles gleich
bezahlen und begleichen die Probleme die
Probleme sind haben wir behandwerker
haben wir genug Fachkräfte
sein oder kann in der Schule sitzen und
was länger
fehlen 10.000 Lehrer und die können
nicht mal bezahlt werden
um mehr Lehrer anzustellen nein nein
Arbeitsverhältnisse müssen komplett
andere sein die Schulen dürfen nicht
mehr marode sein und wenn kein Geld an
den Schulen
wollen müssen sie auch zugeben dass sie
die Leute enteignen wollen
meckertüten
ihre neue Fragen
89 kaputt gegangen die haben sie keine
Macht Quatsch du weißt doch gar nicht
auf der Welt wir haben so schlimmer
das ist überhaupt nicht das was ich
vertrete wir haben heute schon 2,5
Billionen Euro Staatsschulden in
Deutschland meine Frage wäre jetzt bitte
die Steuern sind die sind die gestiegen
seit der Zeit oder sind die gesunken
während diese Schulden gemacht haben
aber Sie können es jetzt nicht auf die
Steuerung fokussieren nein ja aber
Abgaben alles mögliche das war ja
also es wird alles teurer da können auch
die können auch mit der Schuldenpolitik
nachher irgendwann weitermachen aber
irgendwann kommt doomsday irgendwann
kommt
für die richtige Sachen so und da war
schon eigentlich einige Steuern auf
Lebensmittel die Idee zum Beispiel Geld
drucken ist noch bekloppter Welt ist das
Ende eine Ökonomie der Wachstum und auf
Einkommen und auf Leistung setzen das
müssen sie zugeben sie wollen eine
wohlfahrtökonomie wahrscheinlich sind ja
auch ein Anhänger des bedingungslosen
Grund nein tatsächlich
ja interessant wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie